hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar Chris Berg has 9 moving
from pounder mice to phenotype in my
interview or arc of leverage and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminars presented by
blab routes the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by the Jackson
Laboratory founded in 1929 the Jackson
Laboratory Jack's is an independent
non-profit biomedical research
institution its employees discover
precise genomic solutions for disease
and empowers a global biomedical
community in the shared quest to improve
human health the laboratory is a world
leader in mammalian genetics and human
genomics and generating the development
of scientific breakthroughs and improved
therapy with ever greater precision and
speed Jack's educates scientists and
provides critical resources data tools
and services to researchers worldwide it
has a mammalian genetics headquarters in
Bar Harbor Maine a facility in
Sacramento California and a new genomic
medicine facility in Farmington
Connecticut in addition to its National
Cancer Institute designated cancer
center Jax has initiated a cancer
research laboratory in Floral Korea to
learn more visit WWF let's get started
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits you can pose
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind did you so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentations just click on the support
button found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at lower left analysis in today's
speaker David grass PhD senior director
for genetic engineering transgenic
genotyping and reproductive sciences at
the Jackson Laboratory dr. Graf's been
involved in the generation of
genetically modified mice for more than
25 years he received a PhD in molecular
biology from Columbia University in New
York and was a postdoctoral fellow at
the sloan-kettering Institute for cancer
research where the focus of his research
was molecular immunology dr. grass
formerly worked at Bennigan's
Biosciences a biotech company previously
known as DN X where his groups were
responsible for genetically modified
model generation genotyping and in vivo
compound assessment his responsibilities
at Jack's include overseeing the model
generation program dr. Graf's will now
begin his presentation thank you it's
really a pleasure to be here today and
to be able to talk to you about a model
generation platform that we have at Jax
today I'm going to tell you about that
platform focusing mostly on the work
that we do using CRISPR technology I'll
talk to you about project types and
timelines the experience that we've got
that we have doing a lot of these types
of projects I'll show you a couple of
case studies that hopefully will
illustrate things that we think about
doing these studies and I'll also talk
about some of the things that we've
learned from doing the number of
projects that we've done over the last
couple of years but before I get into
the CRISPR technology I wanted to start
and put it in perspective and talk about
the history of genomic engineering in
the mouse and in the 1980s we really
started by taking the approach of the
transgenic approach which allowed us to
do gene addition so to add a gene to the
mouse genome and the technologies that
were used to do gene addition were
generally pro-nuclear and
section or retroviral infection of
embryos of single-cell embryos and I
guess the most utilized technology was
for nuclear injection and we wouldn't we
would in which you would inject into a
single celled I goat at the pro-nuclear
stage a transgene fragment and those
fragments would generally insert into
the mouse genome randomly by a head to
tail away so this allowed us to add a
gene and very often we could do we would
it was useful for dominant mutations we
could create a number of disease model
doing that we could express different
genes to monitor expression like GFP so
that that technology was useful to that
point I should mention that that again
the insertion was random generally in a
head to tail array and the expression of
the transgene all often was determined
not by how many concerted but by the
genomic location that the insert where
the insert landed to take a more
targeted approach and actually be able
to target a gene in the mouse genome we
needed to use mouse embryonic stem cells
so that's the targeted approach that
that really was happening a lot into the
in the 1990s and into into 2000 and
again that required mouse embryonic stem
cells which added a lot of time to the
process because both the mutations were
made on on the stem cells those cells
were then cultured and had to be
injected into Mouse blastocyst embryos
to create chimeric mice which then were
bred to to germline to get germline
transmission but this allowed us to be
able to target individual genes in the
mouse genome which was in
Advancement you know to what we were
doing before in terms of just gene
addition one of the challenges with
doing gene targeting was that when you
were working in mouse embryonic stem
cells you were restricted to strains for
which there was a robust embryonic stem
cell available and that wasn't most of
the strain so a lot of the work was done
on 1/29 background and then they were
black 6 embryonic stem cells that were
developed but what would happen is that
if you wanted to have a mutation on for
example valve C you would create it on
black 6 and then do extensive back
crossing to get to the valve C
background which added an additional one
and a half years even if you use speed
congenic to get there so people were
looking for better technologies to do
gene targeting and the next generation
of beta technologies included
site-specific nucleases of which CRISPR
is one of them and in addition zinc
fingers and tailings are also a
site-specific nuclease assisted genome
editing and the way these technologies
work is that you create a double strand
break which can either be resolved by
non-homologous end joining or in the
context of a targeting vector in the
presence of a targeting vector homology
directed repair so so non-homologous end
joining allows for the deletion of one
or two nucleotides the insertion of one
or two nucleotides that throws off the
reading frame of the protein that you
might be trying to modify and and again
in the car in the presence of a
targeting vector you could also get some
homologous recombination the way CRISPR
works is on this slide and if you look
at the right side of the slide the
little cartoon you can see that that
CRISPR works by we create a a single
guide RNA
it's 20 base pairs from bases I should
say are actually homologous to the
sequence in the genome that we're trying
to target so that that's 20 base pairs
we can you know a genome the trick here
is that it had those 20 base pairs have
to be next to the pam sequence or the
photo spacer adjacent motif and that's
three bases and for the system that
we're primarily using step pyogenes
those three bases are ngg so now those
20 bases you have to find 20 bases that
are next to and ngg sequence and then
that single guide RNA complex with the
cast 9 protein will specifically cut 3
bases from that cam sequence and again
that double-stranded break can be
resolved either by non-homologous end
joining or by homology directed repair
and the reason that we were so excited
that a lot of people are so excited
about the CRISPR technology is that this
gives us it's around a hundred thousand
fold increase in efficiency when you're
thinking about homologous recombination
compared to the standard targeting and
ES cells that we used to that we used to
do so frequently so because it's so
efficient it allows you to bypass
embryonic stem cells which shortens the
timeline and also allows you to do this
work with no selection elements required
so when we used to work in mouse
embryonic stem cells we were always
using via antibiotic resistance genes to
screen for cells that actually got the
targeting vector in this case we don't
need to use those and they don't need
therefore to remove them and it allows
us to make precise single nucleotide
changes without leaving any X
sequence and when I say without leaving
any extra sequence in general we used to
surround our antibiotic resistance genes
neo for example with loxp sites or frt
sites that then we could remove the neo
resistance gene but we'd still have that
loxp site there we don't generally need
to do that when we use CRISPR technology
because it's so efficient and again we
can go into single cell embryos instead
of having to use instead of having to
use mouse embryonic stem cells which
actually allows us enables us to do this
work in many more strains without having
to do extensive that crossing so I
mentioned that there were three
different technologies that all caused
nuclease assisted double strand breaks
and the reason that we favor CRISPR
caste 9 versus zinc finger is Kailen is
that zinc finger and tail end to create
to target another gene in the genome if
you you have to engineer the molecule
the the protein the zinc finger protein
or the tail and protein 2 and then you
have to test to make sure that it's
actually targeting what you want whereas
the specificity in the CRISPR system
comes from the RNA and it's very easy to
synthesize another die RNA that's that
takes a short period of time and it
really it really opens up this
technology makes it a lot easier to use
this technology gives us the potential
to target multiple genes which is really
important when it comes to if the genes
are tightly linked in the genome on the
chromosome and we can target again in
single cell embryos and no need to use a
es cells which means that we can go into
many more strings than we used to be
able to go into directly with mouse
embryonic stem cells and again small
deletions we make through non-homologous
end joining and targeting we use olive
oil
targeting vectors or larger plasma
targeting vectors for homologous
recombination in terms of time line and
costs compared to the conventional gene
targeting in mouse embryonic stem cells
there's a big advantage with CRISPR and
I have on this slide different types of
projects that we that we use that we
that we perform using CRISPR technology
so in Dells are just small deletions or
insertions one or two bases added or
deleted then on this slide where it says
deletion that refers to using two guides
two different guide RNAs and actually
deleting the sequence between those two
guides and then using an awl ago
targeting vector we can add a snip a
single nucleotide change in the genome
or using plasmid targeting vectors we
can add in a reporter gene or create a
conditional knockout and the costs are
quite a bit less the music for doing
these comparative ESL's 81% for an endo
that that's much less and for the most
difficult type of projects that we're
doing right now the conditional knockout
it's around 38% less and from a timeline
perspective for conventional gene
targeting it generally takes a year to a
year and a half to get to germline
transmission I put 12 months as the
baseline here but you can see for these
other types of projects to get germline
transmission is six-and-a-half months to
eight months depending on the complexity
of the project so we've had a lot of
experience doing these different types
of projects so small deletions knockout
fighting those knockouts by deletion
with two guides point mutations knock
ins of two DNA's or conditionals and
based on our experience you can see that
we are comfortable the projects that
highlighted in red of projects that
we're comfortable performing for the
external scientific community and I
should should have mentioned this but at
Jax we function as a core for Jax
investigators so we've been doing this
work for we did this work for several
years prior to actually being able to
offer this capability to the two
scientists outside of Jax and four
scientists outside of Jax we're very
comfortable doing the projects that are
highlighted in red and if these projects
and these projects are standard and if
there are no concerns when we start the
projects about embryonic lethality for
that particular gene for example then we
will guarantee that that if we accept
the project that we will that that we
will get you a mouse or you don't pay
and in addition for some of the projects
that are a little bit harder they are
feasible in mouse embryonic stem cells
and we have our process where we use
CRISPR to do that at this point as well
in terms of our process and workflow in
general on the gene design the guide
synthesis for in Dells we go straight to
microinjection and then we have to
characterize the animals and we do that
for for indulge it's generally a
sequence analysis to determine whether
they are missing or have gained
nucleotide or two in terms of some once
we have founders identified we breed
them to get what we call the n1
generation so these are now animals that
have come through the germline and we
can do that by speed expansion and I'll
mention a little bit more what speed
expansion is that that should that could
give you more n1 animals and and move
your project that forward faster we also
validate that that generation of mice is
exactly what you
as well by sequence analysis prior to
making an assay that is higher
throughput for subsequent identification
of the mice and the strain for deletions
with two guides as well as any project
that requires a mala this recombination
our process is a little bit more
extensive than that we add a guide
evaluation step that we do in vitro and
a cell line of course we have to also
create the targeting vector so do some
molecular biology there but then it
becomes microinjection and analysis of
the founders and the analysis for
homologous recombination experiment is
generally more extensive and when I get
to the case studies I hope to illustrate
the different ways that we evaluate and
validate that we have the mice that we
think we have again speed expansion is
an option both at the founder breeding
stage and for breeding the subsequent n1
and animals and just a quick word about
speed expansion what it is is that we
perform IVF and generally we can start
if we have a male sounder or male n1
animal it allows us to just take the
sperm for from one or two males and take
female generally we can do this with
wild type females from the vet from the
appropriate backup background strain and
that allows us to get a large number of
animals for the next generation so
that's something that we can do that
actually that actually can speed up the
process basically so that it can take
time off the long term the breeding that
needs to be done to generate animals for
subsequent experiments now various
inbred strains have been used for
different dupe for performing different
preclinical models and I put this slide
in this deck just it was
and to mention that at Jack's we have
access to a lot of these different
strains but also we have the
capabilities of working on these
different strains and going directly and
making mutations directly on these
backgrounds and if you've been doing
preclinical work in in in an n OD
background for example because you're
studying diabetes it makes sense to be
actually creating mutations on that same
background as opposed to creating
mutations and then maybe back crossing
it to that strain and we have a lot of
experience going going into those
different strains and we also have
access to a jack the various strains we
have a very robust genetic stability
program which allows us to really have
well annotated genomes so that we and
that Geno genomic information is
important when it comes to designing the
guides and the targeting vectors that we
need so that we have a really efficient
homologous recombination and double
strand break process um the other thing
I would mention is that we have
extensive experience with the strains in
terms of in terms of their reproductive
um in terms of their reproductive
biology so we've used them a lot we know
how many embryos were likely to get and
we scale the experiment appropriately
based on that we have actually these are
just a short list of a lot of the
strains that we've worked on but we've
successfully modified 74 different mouse
strains today um which is in my mind a
number I doubt that they're very many
groups who have approached that kind of
number so it's been a privilege for me
to work at Jackson to work with people
who have this experiences it's been
really great in terms of our experience
making
some types of models using CRISPR
technology getting or going towards more
sophisticated models that require
plasmid targeting vectors but we still
do get deletion projects you're blessed
to do those as well as some in Dell
projects but we're seeing that most of
the work is going more towards I will go
and plasmid targeted vector work and our
success rate has been really good it's
been 97 percent and that's for the
external projects that we've done in the
last two years since we launched this
externally I'd like to switch gears a
little bit and talk to you about a
couple of case studies that we've done i
mean case studies the projects that
we've performed and this will allow you
to see that what the goals were and what
strategies we came up to create those
mice and to also validate them and i
want to mention that these case studies
were done for internal faculty and we
have permission to talk about them and
every project that we do is proprietary
for the group that we perform it for so
we can't talk about the work that we do
without permission but these projects
that I'm going to tell you about where
we have permission to talk about they
were performed for one of the faculty
members of Jack's and the first one in
some created a an allelic series for
familial ALS and we used an audible
mediated knocking strategy to do that so
we saw what was known that there was an
abundance of nonsynonymous snips in
humans in human exon four and based on
that we set out to create an allelic
series so for different snips we wanted
to make in a model for four different
projects basically and the one that I'm
going to focus on is the second one from
the left on this slide it's an R
- system change and we've different
changes but but the strategies that we
used for this are are similar for all of
this in four projects but I'm really
only going to talk about one of them so
the equivalent human codons reside in
Mouse exon four and we said if we set
out to create those mutations again
using a single strand of DNA all ago
strategy which is good for introducing
slip variants for rapid generation of
the template to unit typing the founders
is not as complexes when you use a
plasmid targeting vector and I'll
explain that a little bit more moving
forward but generally we're doing a lot
of sequencing for these types of
projects the challenges can be whether
we can find good guides in the region
that we're trying to to create the
mutation in and again the guy when I
think whether we can find the guides who
want to find 20 base pairs 20 bases that
are next to an ngg sequence for to
create the guide we often you'll see try
to create a silent mutation to reduce
the recutting and i'll try to explain
that as we move forward so this slide
shows three possible guides that we were
evaluating to create this arginine to
cysteine mutation and to do that we're
actually mutating the seed to a tea
so the CGT goes to a two GT and this was
the first guide second guide and the
third guy and what i'm going to point
out is that when i go back to this
second guide that the introduction of
that key mutation that c2 to change
actually destroys the
Pam sequence which is in purple as
opposed to blue those three bases and
because that sequence is disrupted and
changed the guide the guide cast nine
complex can't come back and recut once
we have the mutation that we want that's
something that we try to do and that's
the guide that we used for this project
so on this slide you can see that we
create a single-stranded DNA template
that has the one based change that we
want and it has around sixty base pairs
on either side of it that are halau
homology kamalji arms and that the
create correct mutation destroys the pam
sequence and prevents additional cast
nine DNA cleavage before I move forward
and show you data from this project I
want to talk a little bit about
mosaicism something that we see when we
use this technology and just to show you
what that means on this slide you can
see that if we when we inject the
reagents and bio agents I mean that the
the targeting vector the guide and the
mRNA that that expresses cast nine we
can get those the activity from that mix
happening at the one cell stage which is
what we hope for but we can but also
often those reagents hang around and we
can get activity at to cell and for so
and what that means is that we can get
multiple alleles from one founder Mouse
not just two so let me what does that
mean what is it in a picture form I'll
go to the next slide which shows you an
example of this in this example they
were trying and this is not something
that we did it that was done at Jack's
but yen did it and published it in
developmental biology in 2014 they tried
to mutate the tyrosinase gene which is
required for pigmentation and these are
all potential founders and you can see
that there are some mice that are
completely white which means that the
mutation that they were trying to make
happened at the single cell stage so it
had so you can see it in almost all the
cells but there are some mice that are
mostly agouti here but have a little bit
of white and there some mice that have a
little bit more white but still have
significant amounts of agouti and this
just illustrates that these events these
genetic events happen not at the one
cell stage but a 2 or 4 or somewhere
after that so now to get back to the
project on what we saw in potential
found is 56 four and this is a Sanger
sequencing trace that you can see on the
bottom and you can see that it's
cleaning in the sense that there are
single Peaks except for if you see the
arrow that says CT um there's two peaks
there there's a small peak that
represents that CDT change and a bigger
peak that just represents the C and so
the way we interpret this is that this
is a low frequency T allele so it's a
mosaic animal but we do have some cells
that have what we want
um but it's clean there's no other
mutation there now the next potential
founder 56 one you can see that the
sequence is clean up until that C 2 T
changed but then after that you can see
that there's multiple peaks at the same
at the same in the same areas indicating
that there's probably an in delve in
that Mouse as well so we have a high
frequency T allele but there is the
desired mutation plus in don't and what
we don't
No is whether that endo is on a
different is on the different chromosome
from the mutation that we want or
whether it's actually insists on the
same chromosome so what we do is that we
topo clone the PCR mix and sequence the
individual clones to determine whether
we have a TN and the T the mutation that
we want and the endo on different
chromosomes or whether they're on the
same chromosome if they are on the same
chromosome we generally won't breed that
Mouse because it's not going to be able
to segregate the two mutations away if
they're on different chromosomes we go
ahead and generally have been successful
at getting the desired mutation so to
summarize what we've done on this
project we were able to rapidly produce
founder animals carrying these single
nucleotide variants and we were able to
do it without leaving any residual DNA
modifications like loxp sites or or frt
sites which we would have had to leave
there had we been doing work in mouse
embryonic stem cells and these mice are
now being evaluated phenotypically by by
the investigator at Jack's so that's the
first case study and at this point I'd
like to move on to the second case study
which was a model for Friedreich's
ataxia and we created a conditional real
for for taxon using a double-stranded
DNA plasmid mediated docking strategy a
little bit about Friedreich's ataxia
it's a progressive degenerative disease
causing your degeneration in
cardiomyopathy and the attacks and gene
encodes a mitochondrial protein involved
in iron transport and respiration but
what was known before we started the
project was that
this genius already even knocked out and
animals that were homozygous for this no
mutant it was associated with embryonic
lethality so we had to create a
conditional mutation and use the
double-stranded plasmid strategy
knocking strategy to do that and this is
good for introducing large reporter
genes or creating conditional reels it's
more cumbersome to create these plasmids
than to just synthesize a simple stone
at all ago so that's one of the
challenges in general the maulvis
recombination frequency is lower than
with a single strand and all of those
strategy and the genotyping is a lot
more complex then then what we have to
do to create to characterize in Dells
and and just straight deletions or snips
so our goal was to flank exon 2 with
loxp sites and to do that we look to try
to find sequence that that low sequence
conservation in the introns because we
don't want to affect anything that could
affect the the levels of expression and
we want on the end we hope to be able
identify guide RNA again in the selected
region which we were able to do in this
case
so the targeting vector is going to look
like this where the thin blue lines
represent the loxp sites the arrow is
the exon to and so you can see that that
was we have loxp sites around exon 2 and
then we have around one-and-a-half
kilobases of homology on either side of
those blocks be sites so if you look at
the wild-type exon 2 we were able to
identify possible guides upstream and
downstream in the introns surrounding
exon 2 and
and what we what we did how the way we
designed this was that we put in if you
look at the flocks Exxon 2 which is
towards the bottom of the slide you can
see that that dark blue sequence which
represent the loxp sites if inserted
properly cannot be cut by those guys
anymore because it because it basically
breaks up the sequence of the guide and
that's both the guide upstream and
downstream of exone too so and again we
had one guide that we found upstream and
two possible guides that we found
downstream but they were both by sight
the strategies that we use disrupted by
the insertion of these loxp sites so
that there couldn't be additional
cutting I wanted to talk about our
genotyping strategy for projects that
involve from plasmid knock ins and in
general what we do is a short-range PCR
in this case just to determine whether
the the loxp sites are in the genome and
then we do long-range PCR on both the
5-prime and 3-prime end or the left and
the right homology farm sides and where
one primer is outside of the arm and
another primer is on the and another
primer is within the targeting vector
but it includes the loxp sites as well
and what this means is that we can't get
a long-range PCR product that has loxp
sites unless unless those loxp sites are
at the way are inserted correctly in the
genome so the other thing that we do so
in other words the first short-range PCR
just tells us that these are mice that
we should screen further the long-range
PCR shows us whether it's targeted
properly and the other thing we do is we
do a an assay for the vector
phone to determine whether there are
whether the vector the targeting vector
randomly inserted because if it randomly
inserted it's likely that that vector
background phone would still be in the
genome so we've done that we do that
routinely and I should mention that this
strategy done it as well as done
southern analysis and gotten consistent
results using both of those technologies
I just want to show you some data for
some of these potential founders that we
got from this project and I'm going to
focus on founder 46 2 and 46 5 and what
we're looking for here in the
short-range PCR is we expect to see two
bands one that is the size of wild-type
DNA to that locus and then one that's a
little bit bigger and accounts for the
size of the of the loxp sites that we've
inserted and you can see that 46 - there
are two bands in focus
one band that's a little bit bigger than
the smaller one and I'll show you some
sequence data for that on in a couple of
slides and 446 five and really just
click through this you can see that
there's only one band and it appears to
be actually higher than a wild-type band
so let me go to the sequence data and I
should have mentioned and on the
previous slide that those PCRs that we
do are are you know a major part of our
strategy but we also to validate that
the mouse is right or sequencing are
doing extensive sequencing analysis to
make sure that the change that we're
trying to make is actually there and
it's what we think it is so when we this
is a Sanger sequencing trace for a
founder 46 - and you can see that when
we decon solute the sequence we have
what looks like the wild-type sequence
as well as the loxp sequence which would
indicate that one of the chromosomes has
the homologous recombination event and
the other one did not remain wild-type
so this is a founder that we can bring
and and if the desired mutation that
with with the loxp sites from that now
for forty sixty five where we saw that
one band that looked like it was larger
we have a very clean Sanger sequencing
trace and that trace is consistent with
the sequence being that of the loxp
sites not of wild-type so it actually
appears and this is a rare thing that
happens that we were able to get
homologous recombination in this
particular founder on both chromosomes
and again that doesn't happen that
frequently but in this case it did so to
sum up we were able to rapidly produce
founders carrying the loxp insertions
they were properly inserted it's
important I can't stress enough that
fill up front molecular genotyping and
founders it's really important as well
as doing the same kind of analysis on n1
animals to make sure that you're using
that there really is nothing that you
really understand what's going on with
the animals that you're going to be
using for subsequent preclinical testing
and these animals are currently being
tested with tissue specific crease
strings wanted to talk a little bit
about what we about CRISPR and off
targets um when we design our strategies
each guide is given an off target score
we try to use guides with the lowest off
target score in the event that we can't
find guides with low off target scores
we recommend an off target analysis in
the n1 mice and I should mention that
what I'm talking about here are
predicted off targets in general we
evaluate where these other off targets
could be and in general they're not
closely linked with the taught with the
mutation that we're trying to make we
just need to know that they're there so
that we can
so that we can make sure that we're
segregating them as we breed the animals
so we don't worry that much about off
targets of this sort we have analysed
from seven different projects that
involve 56 different genes and when we
look at the different off target scores
the bottom line is that when the off
target score is below two or when there
is a non canonical Pam sequence we don't
see any off target events however when
you have a canonical Pam and a higher
score than then two we have been able to
see events I will mention that there I
know that there has been a publication
probably around a month ago I'm in
Nature Methods that that indicated that
they found single nucleotide variants
and a number a large number of them in a
CRISPR experiment that we did and we are
currently doing some work to evaluate
whether we can reproduce that kind that
same result in some of the animals that
we've already made but we do have
questions about that paper in terms of
the lineage of the different dung of the
other mice that they analyzed versus the
control and we note that there is no
known CRISPR mechanism by which single
nucleotide variants would come up so we
do have a lot of questions about that
but we are following up and I know a
number of groups you know in addition to
Jack's are also following up on that on
that publication
I wanted to talk about some of the
things that we've learned by doing the
number of projects that we've been able
to do we do a large number of projects
not only for our faculty but for people
outside of Jax one thing that we found
that we didn't anticipate originally is
that we've often been asked to create
single nucleotide polymorphisms in genes
that may be associated with embryonic
lethality and even though we're making
heterozygotes what we find is that
sometimes during the process we can
create the creation of in Dells
knockouts can actually make it more
difficult to get the desired mutation
that we're trying to make so we've had
some experience trying to titrate the
reagents to try to favor the homologous
recombination of our ala go into versus
the in del formation and that's been
something that we didn't really
anticipate when we really started doing
one of these projects another challenge
comes up often not that often actually
is low efficiency cutting and
fortunately that doesn't really happen
that often strain specific reproductive
biology limitations just refers to the
fact that different strains behave
differently in terms of their ability to
expanded injection and and also in terms
of the number of embryos and the quality
of embryos that you're able to generate
from them our experience and
reproductives on a biology is really
helpful in helping us scale the
experiments appropriately when working
on various different strains potential
impact the DNA variation on gene editing
experiments just as as you might expect
it's important to make sure that you are
designing your experiment consistent
with the genome that you're trying to
target so just because you have a guide
that might work well in black 6 there
might be a polymorphism in another
strains and you should be
aware of that and create the appropriate
guy for the appropriative stream and one
last thing that that I wanted to mention
is that we've seen that we've seen
random insertion of the plot of the
targeting vector when we've done
experiments involving plasmid targeting
vectors in general this hasn't been a
big problem because we've been able to
upon bringing the animals those plasmid
that have been inserted improperly in
the wrong place have have been able have
been segregated away so hasn't been a
very big issue but it's just something
that if you're doing this in your own
lab you want to make sure that you're
aware of so I hope I've been able to
communicate to you that that CRISPR can
generate new mouse models for faster and
cheaper than ever before that the
success really depends on really soil
characterization of both the founder and
n1 animals and at Jack's we really bring
I think the genetic engineering the
reproductive science experience the
animal husbandry expertise to model
generation as well as the access to
almost 9,000 different mouse strains and
this technology really opens it up to
allow you to work on a lot of different
mouse strains I want to thank my
colleagues of the genetic engineering
technologies group led by Bill Burris
and I'd also like to thank cat Lux who's
the investigator at Jack's who allowed
us to talk about both of those projects
that we perform for her group thanks and
I'll take any questions that you have
thank you to dr. Graf's for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box down by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. grass will answer as many
questions as time permits the first
question is do you have a lot of
experience creating conditional mutation
um yes we actually have we get asked to
create conditional mutations a lot and
and I would say being at Jack's one of
the advantages that we have is that is
that we actually have access to a lot of
the different Crees strains that you
might want to use subsequent to having
that your your conditional real and I
will remind people that it's important
to match the background strain and so
having access to all those creep strains
making sure that if you're creating the
model on a black 6j that your crease
train is on black 6j that's important
and in general as in the case study that
I showed I think the second one we
generally use a strategy of using a
large plasmid targeting vector to create
those mutations are you concerned about
off-target events and how does Jeff
address this issue um we try to our best
to design around all the predicted off
targets that you could have so when I
say predicted lock off targets each
guide that we have is given a score and
we look at the different potential off
sites where the be creating
double-stranded cutting in the genome
and if we feel that that it's likely
that we might get an off target event we
will suggest that that we do off target
analysis to determine whether that
happened or not but in general those
events can be segregated away and then I
think I mentioned this during the
presentation but there has been a report
that there may be other mutations
associated with the CRISPR technology
some questions about that paper in terms
of the lineage
of the mice the mechanism by which they
are they think that this happened
because I don't think there is a known
mechanism for how CRISPR would
facilitate single nucleotide changes and
I will also mention that those
nucleotide changes weren't predictable
meaning they weren't associated with any
predict with any with any particular
sequence so we think that there's a
chance that this may be explained by
just genetic drift between the founder
animals that were evaluated and Lee and
the reference genome and control Mouse
that they that they were used but at any
rate we are evaluating whether we're
seeing whether we're seeing that same
thing in our mice and that evaluation
hopefully we'll have some data in the
next couple of months on that looks like
we have time for one more question and
it is do you think CRISPR will eliminate
the utility of randomly integrated
transgenic line um I would say that I
think that that um that there's a place
in the toolbox for all of these
different technologies and I think that
that randomly inserted lines have been
used and effectively to study various
things again the dominant mutations to
to look at the expression from
particular promoter z' and use a a gene
like GFP to tell you where expression is
happening
I think it's been valuable and also to
to express genes in a deregulated manner
I think that if you're looking to get a
variety of different expression levels
in mice then actually that transgenic
approach that random approach may be
useful because you can create those mice
evaluate different different founder
lines and each one of them may have
different different expression levels
and then you can choose the ones that
best suit your research so I don't think
it will eliminate that but I do think
that it's a great too
all that really has allowed us to move
forward and create a lot of different
new mutations quickly Thanks well I
would like prior election once again
stamps after grass for his presentation
do you have any final comment um no I
would just like to say it was a pleasure
to be able to be here I thought that I
hope that this presentation you know it
was informative and helped people in the
audience who are either doing it in your
own lab or if there's any way that we at
the Jackson lab can assist you you know
we'd love to love to be able to discuss
that with you well I would like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed via email we would like to
thank our sponsor the Jackson Laboratory
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the sheet' button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
January 21st 2018 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay and we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues and you
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye